[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance it is in retrospect amazing
that Trump spoke to the two houses of
Congress at all because the address did
not take place inside his cocoon six
weeks into his presidency and he is
already silenced virtually all stimuli
coming from outside that cocoon the
evidence that could tell him the truth
that more Americans disapprove of him
than any other incoming executive since
such polling data has been compiled that
efforts to remove him from office or are
already coalescing and sharpening and
especially that much of his own
administration has shown signs of
turning on him and he's dividing quickly
into two camps I was trying to clean up
his messes by routing around him and
those who are actively undermining him
by leaks and even with on the record
contradictions Trump of course cannot
literally can not hear any of this
he must be loved worshipped obeyed
that's why there is a cocoon that's why
there is a cocoon where there were lines
six blocks long to get into his speech
at CPAC when the public wasn't even
admitted to CPAC so there could not have
been any lines out on the street that's
why he had to cancel on the White House
Correspondents Dinner before the
correspondence could refuse to invite
him or before he was faced with
venturing outside the cocoon and getting
mauled by a comic
that's why his staff reportedly feeds
him only stories he will like from
propagandist sites like Fox News and
Breitbart that's why the Baltimore
Orioles denied us a potential test of
the density of the cocoon when the
team's chief operating officer said he
would not invite Trump to throw out the
ceremonial first pitch on baseball's
Opening Day what a choice 46,000
screaming fans who could cheer him to be
cheered for chance to be booed I there's
the rub and then there are the leaks
Trump is insane enough that he could
repeatedly scream about the illegal
leaks when he spent the campaign
literally every one of the last 30 days
164 times in one month quoting the
illegal leaks reportedly provided by
Russia to Julian Assange and WikiLeaks
he loves WikiLeaks he could rail about
catching the leakers and investigating
them and punishing them while Reince
Priebus was bed
the FBI to leak about Trump and Russia
and while the White House got
congressman newness and Senator Burke to
leak about Trump and Russia he could
attack the FBI and CIA
self-destructively and specifically
about leakers inside their own
organizations while his own house is
such a sieve that his faithful toady
Sean Spicer reportedly collects all his
staffers phones to check if they have
been leaking and not only does that
story itself leak out within days but
when it does it contradicts Trump's
mindless assertion that the news media
just makes up stories about him if they
are making stories up about him why are
you checking who is leaking those
stories and when the White House wants
specific outlets banned from news
briefings Spicer does it even though
just two months ago Spicer said they
only do that in dictatorships this makes
no sense
not even for a crazy man inside a cocoon
confirming what you ardently deny retro
actively declaring the presidency you
serve a dictatorship it makes no sense
unless we postulate that what Trump
calls leaks and what the rest of the
world calls leaks are different things
he's not obsessed with leaks from inside
the cocoon getting out he is obsessed
with leaks from outside the cocoon
getting in Russian scandal is not a
problem for him because it could send
him to an impeachment trial or the
penitentiary or both it is a problem to
him because stories about it leak into
the cocoon and damage his perfect world
in which he was elected because
everybody loves him the same with the
loss of the popular vote to him that's
not about presidential legitimacy or a
mandate he just cannot permit it to be
true because it means he finished second
in something what he calls leaks are in
fact reality permeating the wall of his
cocoon as historians and medical
researchers gain new information and new
insight the evidence mounts that the
primary intellectual damage done to
President Woodrow Wilson during his
stroke in October 1919 was that it
short-circuited the part of the brain
that would normally have allowed
President Wilson to understand the
reality and grab
the damage to his brain it's called an
acid nausea and it is in essence a
physical form of denial as the
psychologist David Dunning once told the
New York Times an annus agnostic patient
who is paralyzed simply does not know he
is paralyzed if you put a pencil in
front of them and ask them to pick up
the pencil in front of their left hand
they won't do it and you ask them why
and they'll say well I'm tired or I
don't need a pencil maybe Trump has that
if not he has manufactured a cocoon for
himself in which he might as well have
it this can be tragic for the nation
some historians believe Wilson's Annis
Ignacio made it impossible for him to
compromise about the League of Nations
his stroke may have in part led to the
Second World War our tragedy with a
president who will not or cannot allow
reality to leak into his cocoon
who knows what nightmare we will get but
it is axiomatic that authoritarians in
power even the ones who don't have an
Assad no CEO or regular old denial begin
by shutting out dissenting voices and
invariably end up by shutting down
dissenting voices resist peace